ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
BARRICADE CAN.
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE.
CALDERON CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP. EIGHT MEN FLORA
[inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL ALL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
[inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY.
LEVINE LIMON [inaudible]
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMOS.
RAMOS THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER.
WICKS.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT -- A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE SET OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY OSHA PROPOSED.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THE CHEROKEE ELDER WAS SPEAKING
TO YOUNG CHILDREN OF THE TRIED.
TRYING TO PREPARE THEM FOR LIFE.
HE TOLD THEM THAT THERE WAS A
FEROCIOUS BATTLE GOING ON WITHIN
HIM.
IT WAS A FIGHT BETWEEN TWO
WORLDS. ONE WAS A WORK OF
COMPASSION CARING.
KINDNESS HOPE AND LOVE.
THE OTHER WAS A WOLF OF
SELFISHNESS GREED.
ANGER FEAR AND INDIFFERENCE.
THEN THE ELDER ADDED.
THIS SAME FIGHT IS RAGING WITHIN
EACH OF YOU.
AND ALSO WITHIN EACH AND EVERY
HUMAN BEING IN THE WORLD.
THE CHILDREN QUIETLY ABSORB THE
ELDERS WORDS.
THEN ONE CHILD ASK.
WHICH WOLF WILL WIN.
THE ELDER RESPONDED SAYING.
WHICH EVERYONE WE FEED.
THIS CONSTANT BATTLE IS GOING ON
WITHIN US ALL.
THE WHAT WE FEED WILL MAKE ALL
THE DIFFERENCE.
NUMBER ME DOWN CIVIC KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO AS SHE LEADS US
IN THE PLEDGE MISS KOREA.
RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR HEART READY
BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
ISRAEL.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE
THIRTEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
RECENTLY MET AT TEN AM ON KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THIS
ON THE PRESIDING CHEAPER
DEDUCTIBLES AND AT THE DESK
REGISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MR
FLOOR SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS.
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES THERE ARE NO
EXCUSED ABSENCES FOR THE DAY
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW SOMEONE
MEMBERS.
OUR CAN WICKS AND WALDRON TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH GUESTS WILL
BE SEATED AT HER DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS IRWIN.
AND LACKEY TO SPEAK ON IT IN
GERMAN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW COMMITTEES TO NOT.
COMMITTEES TO NOTICE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO ALLOW THE
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AS BEFORE --
TWO BARGES PENDING RE REFER ALL
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE AND I'LL TO ALLOW THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE SB THREE
SIXTY NINE HERTZBERG PENDING WE
REFERRAL FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THAT'S ALL FOR NOW.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
I LIKE TO CALL IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVID CHIU MISTER CHIU
YOU HAVE GUESTS THAT JOINED US
TODAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AS CHAIR OF THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE THE TWENTY NINETEEN A.
P. I. CAPITAL ASSOCIATION PECA
INTERNS.
WE HAVE SEVEN INTERNS WERE GONNA
BE SPENDING THE NEXT TEN WEEKS
IN TURN IN IN OUR API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS OFFICES.
I'M PROUD THAT OUR CAUCUS HAS
BEEN ABLE TO SPONSOR THIS
INTERNSHIP FOR THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS TO PREPARE THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERS IN THIS
BUILDING.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE
TWENTY NINETEEN A PEAK A SUMMER
INTERNS
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GUEST
WITH US TODAY MS RUBIO YOU HAVE
GUESTS TO THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY IN THE GALLERY IS
A GROUP OF THIRD AND FOURTH
GRADERS FROM REDWOOD ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL.
OF FINE TENER UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHERE I SPENT SIXTEEN
YEARS AS A TEACHER EVERY YEAR I
HAVE THE PLEASURE OF WELCOMING
STUDENTS FROM REDWOOD TO THE
CAPITAL FOR A GLIMPSE.
INTO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
ENVIRONMENT THE CLASS THE LAWS
AFFECTING EACH OF WHAT OF OUR
LIVES.
IT HOME WITH ME TO RECOGNIZE A
SMALL FRACTION OF THE FUTURE
GENERATION WE STRIVE TO LIFT UP
AND IMPROVE THE QUALITY QUALITY
OF LIFE.
FOR PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
THE STUDENTS AND THEIR
CHAPERONES TO OUR BEAUTIFUL
CAPITALS THE BUILDING -- AND THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO WELCOME
REDWOOD ELEMENTARY SCHOOL KIDS
.
AN ASSEMBLY WOMAN YEAH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTERACTION MEMBERS THANK YOU
MA'AM.
I HAVE MY YOUNG LESS STATERS --
CLASS FOR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
EVERY YEAR I'VE HAD A GROUP OF
HIGH SCHOOL JUNIORS AND TEEN
YEARS -- PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM THE PROGRAM STARTS IN
DECEMBER AND APPLE MANY TO NAY
GRADUATION IN JULY TODAY THEY'LL
BE DEBATING THE BUILDING
COMMITTEE AND THEY WILL HAVE A
MOCK ASSEMBLY.
FLOOR SESSION ALONG THE WAY ALSO
AND SO THIS IS THE PRIDE OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT OUT HERE AND THEY I
AM CONFIDENT THAT THEY WILL BE
HERE IN MY SEAT WHEN DAY.
PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME MY YOUNG
LEGISLATORS
[inaudible]
FOR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
MEMBERS GEN.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER FROM MY DAD
ASKS FOR A SPECIAL PRESENTATION
AND MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS -- I'M HERE TODAY IN
KIND OF A MELANCHOLY WAY. TO
RECOGNIZE STEVE MCCARTHY WHO HAS
BEEN WITH-- THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS FOR THE PAST FEW YEARS
AND HAS BEEN SUCH A TREMENDOUS
ASSET TO US.
AND WHILE HE'S MOVING ON TO NEW
ADVENTURES AND LEAVING US -- WE
WANTED TO COMMEMORATE HIS TIME
WITH US AND THANK HIM.
AS WELL AS WISH HIM WELL SO --
STEVE MCCARTY IS JOINED TODAY BY
HIS LOVELY WIFE SHERRY AND SONS
LUKE AND TATE. FIVE YEARS AGO
STEVE JOIN THE ASSEMBLY IS THE
POLICY DIRECTOR. FOR THE PAST
FOUR YEARS I HAVE WORKED CLOSELY
WITH HIM WHEN I WAS A REPUBLICAN
FLOOR LEADER AND NOW AS MINORITY
LEADER.
AND HE HAS SMART CAPABLE FOCUSED
AND MOST OF ALL IT DECENT HUMAN
BEING.
I HAVE HE IS A TREMENDOUSLY
TRUSTWORTHY AND THAT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS UP HERE IN.
THE CAPITAL THAT WE LEARN RIGHT
AWAY THAT THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT YOU CAN TRUST AND
STEVE MCCARTHY IS INTEGRITY IS
AN UNIMPEACHABLE SO.
I THINK THAT -- IT'S OUR LOSS IS
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO FILL IN THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS -- HE'S BEEN AN ASSET TO
US FOR MANY YEARS AND WE HAVE
REALLY I THINK CHANGE THE WAY
OUR FLOOR OPERATED.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SO WORK
CLOSE.
CLOSELY ACROSS THE AISLE.
GET THINGS DONE ON THE FLOOR
THAT NEEDED TO BE DONE MAKE SURE
THAT THE FLOOR OPERATED SMOOTHLY
MADE SURE THAT OUR CAUCUS
MEMBERS KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON
OUR POLICY AND THAT ANIL
ANALYSIS WOULD DONE -- TO THE
BEST OF THEIR ABILITY WHILE HE
BASICALLY MANAGED TO OUR TEAM OF
POLICY -- FOLKS.
SO.
HE'S ALWAYS BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PROCESSAND PROCEDURES WHICH
IS.
TANTAMOUNT REALLY OVER THE
POLITICS AND THAT MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE IT HAS REALLY CHANGED
THE WHERE FLOOR OPERATE.
HE'S ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
SETTING A GREAT EXAMPLE AND I
KNOW HIS FAMILY AS PROUD OF HIM.
AND SO ARE WE STEVE IS LEAVING
FOR NEW ADVENTURES.
AND WE WISH HIM AND HIS FAMILY
THE BEST AND THAT IS HOW MUCH WE
WILL MISS HIM WE CAN DO IS NOT
REALLY ENOUGH WORDS TO SAY.
BUT I'M PRETTY SURE HE WON'T
MISS MY SIX AM PHONE CALLS.
THAT I ALWAYS HAD FOR HIM ON
SESSION DAYS SO.
WE DO HAVE.
WE DO HAVE A RESOLUTION TO
COMMEMORATE.
STEVE MCCARTY SOMETIME WITH US.
IN ON BEHALF OF OUR WHOLE
ASSEMBLY WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO AUSTIN TO
THIS HOUSE.
AND I'D LOVE TO HAVE YOU BACK SO --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PER SEARCH PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER SB
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT WINNER FROM THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE
TO WITHDRAW THE FOLLOWING BUDGET
TRAILER BILL FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING TO TAKE THEM
UP ON THIRD. FOR THIRD READING
WITHOUT REFERENCE FILE THOSE
BILLS ARE SB EIGHTY SB EIGHTY
ONE SB.
NINETY MISS FLORA FOR WHAT
PURPOSE SIR THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WE OBJECT ASK FOR ROLL
CALL VOTE.
MR FLORA IS WITHHOLDING IN THIS
CASE MISTER CALDERON MOVES.
AND MAYES RUBIO SECONDS.
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER FLORES ASKING FOR NO.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
HIGH THOUGH.
MR FLOORS ASKING FOR NOW.
THIS TAKES.
FORTY ON THE ROLL SUSPENSION.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY TWO KNOWS TWELVE
THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE TAKING UP
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT FOURTEEN SENATE BILL
FOR SEVENTY WITH THE MEMON SIXTY
EIGHT WITH THE MOMENT SIX FORTY
SEVEN WITH THE MEMONS FIVE
HUNDRED WITH AMENDMENTS
318-819-2220 418-366-1401
322-334-3663. 833-994-69518 WITH
THEM AT SIX TWENTY TWO AT THE
MOMENT 295-324-3793 EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE SIX FORTY SIX AND
SEVEN FIFTY ONE ALL BILLS HAVE
BEEN DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY FIVE THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FORTY FIVE ACR NINETY ONE BY
MISTER JONES SAWYER THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOMETHING CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY ONE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
JONES SAWYER RELATIVE TO SECOND
CHANCES MONTH.
YOUR JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ACR
NINETY ONE RECOGNIZES JUNE AS
SECOND CHANCES MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS RESOLUTION EXPRESSES THE
IMPORTANCE OF EXISTING
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IN PERSON
PROMOTING TO SUCCESSFUL REENTRY
UP FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
AND GIVING THEM A SECOND CHANCE.
FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS HAVING A
CRIMINAL RECORD HAS ADDED
BARRIERS TO SECURING HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT WHICH OFTEN RESULTS
IN MISS ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
AND LOST CHANCES OF A BETTER
LIFE FOR THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES.
ACR NINETY ONE SHOWS THE
LEGISLATURE'S COMMITMENT TO
INTEGRATION AND BUILDING
STRONGER AND SAFER COMMUTING
MEANING THESE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
RESOLUTION MR JONES SAWYER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO AUTHORS.
MR JOHNSON -- IS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON ACR NINETY ONE CLERK
LOOKING THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE RATHER FORTY NINE CO
AUTHORS ADDED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
ON THE SECOND READING FILE ITEM
NINETEEN SB FOUR SIXTY NINE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
BY MR GRAY.
CLERK WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
CENTRAL FOR SIXTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAY.
MR GRAY ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT THAT'S
BEFORE SIXTY NINE WOULD
ESTABLISH A REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA'S BOARD -- TO ISSUE A
MERGER REGULATIONS TO ENSURE DUE
PROCESS IN THE EVENT THAT WE
WOULD BE -- ESTABLISHING A OR
SUSPENDING RATHER HORSE RACING
RUSSIAN SUB THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE BURKE.
THANK YOU MISTER GRACIE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES
HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL IS OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE. TO THE THIRD
READING FILE
MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP.
A COUPLE OF CONCURRENCE ITEMS.
MEMBERS THIS IS ON THE
CONCURRENCE FILE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY FOUR AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
ONE BY MR OBERNOLTE.
MEMBERS [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING A
BUSINESS.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR A.
B. THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE COOPERATE.
AS SOMETHING WILL THIRTEEN SIXTY
ONE BY SOME REMEMBER OBERNOLTE
AND ACTUALLY THE CIVIL ACTIONS.
MR OBERNOLTE YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE WITH MINOR TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE IN CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER OF NINETY SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY SEVEN THIS IS AJ ARE.
TO BY MR VOEPEL CLERK MARIE.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION TO BUY
SOMETHING MEMBER VOEPEL AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE FEDERAL
PELL GRANT PROGRAM.
MR VOEPEL.
MS SPEAKER MEMBERS [inaudible]
EIGHT J. R. TWO IS MINOR AND
TECHNICAL CHANGES WERE MADE.
AND WITH THAT SAID I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A YES VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS VOEPEL.
A NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRED ABOUT.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL.
CALVET I SEVENTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO START
TAKING A BUDGET ITEMS.
THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE.
SB.
NINETY WITHOUT REFERENCE FILE SP.
NINETY THE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL NINETY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
MR CHANEY MAIL BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER SB NINETY
IMPLEMENTS SUPPLEMENTAL IN FOR
PLANTING PAYMENTS FOR CALPERS
AND CAL STAR FIRST.
THAT WILL SAVE THE STATE SCHOOL
DISTRICT INCOMMUNICADO EDGES
BILLIONS OVER THE NEXT THREE
DECADES.
SB NINETY APPROPRIATE THREE
BILLION DOLLARS A SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS FOR CALPERS TO ADDRESS
THE STATE'S UNFUNDED LIABILITY.
THE BILL APPROPRIATES A TOTAL OF
TWO POINT NINE BILLION IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THROUGH. TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TO PAY DOWN THE STATE
CHAIR OF CALLOUS DOORS UNFUNDED
LIABILITY.
IT ALSO APPROPRIATES FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND MONEY TO REDUCE THE
CAL STIRS IN CALPERS SCHOOL
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION RATE.
BY ONE POINT 003% WHICH WILL
GIVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE MUCH NEEDED RELIEF.
AND FINALLY THE BILL APPROPRIATE
SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY MILLION IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TO
ADDRESS THE SCHOOL EMPLOYERS
SHARE.
OF THE CALPERS UNFUNDED
LIABILITY.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT NOW.
FAMOUS CHIANG MISTER OBERNOLTE
OR RECOGNIZE MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE SB NINETY
THIS BILL WILL APPROPRIATE MORE
THAN FOUR BILLION DOLLARS TO
PAYING DOWN TO THE STATE'S LONG
TERM PERSON STIRS LIABILITIES.
IT ALSO APPROPRIATES OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR PAYING DOWN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS LONG TERM
LIABILITIES AND LASTLY
APPROPRIATE OVER A HUNDRED BILL
A WAR OVER ONE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR PAYING DOWN AT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT RETIREMENT
CONTRIBUTIONS.
THIS LAST PIECE I ACTUALLY WISH
HAD BEEN TREATED DIFFERENTLY I
WISH THAT ALL OF THAT MONEY WAS
GOING TOWARDS LONG TERM
LIABILITY REPAYMENT BECAUSE
PAYING THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CONTRIBUTIONS ALTHOUGH IT'S NICE
FOR THEM.
REALLY DOESN'T DO ANYTHING FOR
THE LONG TERM DEBT BUT OVERALL
THIS IS A GREAT BILL.
JUST PUT IT IN CONTEXT HOWEVER
ARE LONG TERM LIABILITY FOR
PURRS IS CURRENTLY SIXTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN FIRSTERS IS ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS SO
THIS ALTHOUGH VERY HELPFUL IS
JUST A GOOD START I ORIGINAL%
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS ROBIN ALL THE
SAME NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
COUPLE OF THE ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE A
NO
NEED TO RUN MEMBERS.
SAFETY NEVER TAKES A HOLIDAY.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
CIRCLE CLOSER ALL.
TELL YOU ABOUT I SEVENTY SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE THE
FILE.
THIS IS SB.
EIGHTY SB EIGHTY CORPORATION.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY HUMAN
SERVICES MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MUCH
BIGGER SB EIGHTY IS OUR HUMAN
SERVICES.
TRAILER BILL THIS IS THE BILL
WERE WE ARE REALLY HELPING THE
MOST VULNERABLE AND POOREST
CALIFORNIANS.
WERE INVESTING IN OUR SENIORS BY
INCLUDING THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM THAT'S ONE OF
MANY INVESTMENTS WE MADE TOWARD
SENIORS THIS YEAR.
WE ALSO ARE IN THE SECOND YEAR
OF OUR CAL WORKS INVESTMENT.
GIVING CAL WORKS A MUCH NEEDED
INCREASE FIRST INCREASE OUR
CHARACTERS HAD IN DECADES VERY
PROUD TO BE ABLE.
TO VOTE ON THAT TODAY.
IN ADDITION WE'RE ALSO MOVING
FORWARD OUR CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM IT'S A OF REFORM THAT
STARTED REALLY AS WE ARE
RESHAPING OUR FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND LASTLY WE'RE TRYING TO
FURTHER SUPPORT IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES AS WELL AS THE SS I SS
P. PROGRAM AS THEY ARE
UNDERGOING.
MAJOR CHANGES THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY AGAIN RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE FOR SB.
EIGHTY THANK MUCH TAMER SURE
OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB EIGHTY COLLEGE THIS BILL
CONTAINS MANY VERY SUPPORTABLE
PROVISIONS BUT UNFORTUNATELY
ALSO CONTAINS SEVERAL VERY
UNSUPPORTABLE ONES IN THE MOST.
EGREGIOUS PROVISION IN THIS BILL
IS PROBABLY THE FACT THAT IT
WITH HOLDS NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT FUNDING FROM ANY
COUNTY WITH AN EXPIRED
BARGAINING AGREEMENT.
WITH THEIR I. HSS SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND LESS THAT BARGAIN
AGREEMENT IS RENEWED WITHIN
NINETY DAYS OF FACT FINDING
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
JUSTIFICATION FOR WITHHOLDING
THOSE FUNDS I URGE A NO VOTE.
THINGS ROLLING MS RACE HERE
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM INCREDIBLY PROUD OF
THE HUMAN SERVICES INVESTMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE AND INCLUDED
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
IN PARTICULAR THE FOLLOWING I'M
HAPPY TO SEE NECESSARY CHANGES
WITHIN THE CAL WORKS HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY
PERIODS.
INCREASING ACCESS TO IMPORTANT
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE FOR MOST
VULNERABLE.
AS WELL AS BEING I'M SO THRILLED
TO SEE THE AYE HSS MAINTENANCE
OF EFFORT AND RATE INCREASES.
WELL I CAN EASILY GO ON AND ON
ABOUT THE GREAT INVESTMENTS
WHICH BUILD.
OUR SAFETY SOCIAL NET SAFETY NET.
AND HELP THOSE MOST VULNERABLE
MARGINALIZED I AM HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS TRAILER BILL.
NAME ADDRESS SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
COUPLE OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT ABOUT
AYE SIXTY TWO NO SIX THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE THIS IS SB [inaudible]
EIGHTY ONE CLOCK RATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHTY ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATES
TO THE BUDGET.
MR TANK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
EIGHTY ONE IS OUR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TRAILER BILL YOU'RE ALL
AWARE THAT.
THERE WAS A STUDY RELEASED
SAYING THAT WE HAVE -- ONE POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLAR SHORTFALL IN
OUR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
FUNDING.
WHILE WE WERE NOT ABLE TO MAKE
AND CLOSE THAT GAP THIS YEAR
THIS IS A HUGE DOWN PAYMENT
TOWARD THE EFFORT ONE OF THE
LARGEST ON GOING COMMITMENT THAT
WE MADE THIS YEAR WHICH WAS A
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLAR.
GENERAL FUND ONGOING ALLOCATION
FOR BROAD BASE RATE INCREASED
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY IN ADDITION IN THE
TRAILER BILL WE COMMITTED TO
FURTHERING WORK TOGETHER TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN CLOSE THE
GAP.
BY WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WORKING WITH ARE VERY
STAKEHOLDERS WORKING WITH ALL
OUR KEY PARTNERS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE BECAUSE WE KNOW THE POP
THE POPULATIONS GROWING.
AND THE NEED IS GROWING WE
REALLY NEED TO GET AHEAD OF THIS
CURVE.
AGAIN -- WE ALSO HAD MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AROUND REGIONAL CENTERS INCLUDE
IN THIS TRAILER BILL -- WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE ARE
INVESTING DOLLARS THAT THESE
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE WORKING AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE TO SERVICE IS
VERY IMPORTANT POPULATION.
SO WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I DON'T ON SB.
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHANG MISTER OBERNOLTE ARE
RECOGNIZED I THINK THIS IS
BIGGER RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
THE EIGHTY ONE THE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN.
PROVIDER RATE INCREASES AT THIS
BILL AND ACTS ARE DESPERATELY
NEEDED IN CALIFORNIA HOWEVER AS
THE BUDGET YEAR POINTED OUT.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S OWN RATE
STUDY RELEASED EARLIER THIS YEAR
SAYS THAT OVER ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS.
OF ADDITIONAL RATE INCREASES AS
NECESSARY JUST TO BRING RATES UP
TO WHERE THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
HAD THEY NOT BEEN FROZEN FOR THE
LAST DECADE.
ALSO A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED THAT
THIS TRAILER BILL DOES NOT ENACT
A PERMANENT SOLUTION TO THE
PROBLEMS OF UNIFORM HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE AND HALF THE BILLING
THAT HAVE BEEN PLAGUING OUR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES FOR MANY
YEARS NOW.
THIS IS A DROP IN THE BUCKET A
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
AGAINST A ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR NEED IS ACTUALLY
VERY DISAPPOINTING.
AND I WISH THAT MORE HAD BEEN
DONE THIS YEAR WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AND WE FAILED TO DO IT
BUT NONETHELESS THIS BILL MOVES
THE BALL IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
SO I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
MR LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION FOR
JUST A MINUTE I THINK THAT THIS
IS A VERY VERY SAD REFLECTION ON
THIS BODY.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN THIS INSTITUTION.
WE'VE BEEN PROMISING THIS PART
OF OUR POPULATION WE'RE GOING TO
GET TO YOU WE'RE GOING TO HELP
YOU.
FOLKS IT'S REALLY DISGUSTING
THAT WE HAVE SINCE I'VE BEEN
HERE WE'VE HAD.
SURPLUS AFTER SURPLUS AFTER
SURPLUS.
BUT YET.
WE'LL GIVE YOU A DOWN PAYMENT.
WHAT THE HECK IS THAT?
A DOWN PAYMENT.
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE WALKING PAST
SOMEBODY.
A PERSON WHO'S DYING OF THIRST.
AND YOU LOOK AT THAT PERSON YOU
SAY I HAVE A SPRAY BOTTLE I'M
GONNA BE COMPASSIONATE WOULD
GIVE YOU A COUPLE SPORTS OF
MISSED [inaudible]
GOOD LUCK.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING.
THIS IS SAD.
THIS IS VERY SAD AND HERE'S THE
OTHER REALITY IF YOU VOTE NO.
ON THIS DAY LOOKS LIKE YOU CARE.
NOT AT ALL.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
AND WHAT WHAT WE'VE DONE WE
SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF OURSELVES
BECAUSE OF THESE PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE ADVOCATES LIKE MANY OF
THESE OTHER WORTHY CAUSES HAVE.
THEY COME IN THEY THEY TELL US
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS AND HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS THIS IS THE
WORLD FOR THESE PEOPLE.
THESE PEOPLE EXPECT US TO HELP
THEM.
AND WHAT ARE WE DOING WITH DR
I'M TONY SOME OF THE SERVICES
ARE GONE NOW.
IF WE SUPPORT THIS AND THIS IS
ALL WE HAVE TO OFFER MANY OF
THESE SERVICES ARE GONE.
LIKE I HAVE ALL THE ISSUES THAT
I'M GONNA DRESS BUT I'VE SAID
ENOUGH.
THIS IS.
REALLY REALLY EMBARRASSING WE
SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF OURSELVES
AND THIS DOWN PAYMENT STUFF
DOESN'T CUT IT I'M SORRY.
MR FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER-- LAYS
IN GERMAN I WILL TELL YOU.
THAT EVERYTHING'S BEEN SAID
TODAY'S TRUE.
BUT I WILL ALSO TELL YOU.
THAT AFTER DOING A HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE FOR INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
POPULATION CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE NEED.
TO NOT ONLY MONEY.
BUT MONIES AFTER THE FACT.
WE NEED TO RESTRUCTURE.
THE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THE REGIONAL
CENTERS.
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO PUT IN
PLACE.
THE ABILITY TO HAVE PROVIDERS.
WE CAN THROW AS MUCH MONEY AT
THIS ISSUE AS WE WANT.
BUT IT WON'T.
FIX WHAT'S WRONG.
WE NEED TO BUILD THE PLAN.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO CERTIFY
WORKFORCE SO THEY CAN MAKE MORE
MONEY.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE THEIR RELEGATED
IS MINIMUM WAGE WORKERS.
AND I DON'T WANT TO DISPARAGE
HIM BECAUSE I APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING THAT THEY DO.
BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY CREATING
BABYSITTERS.
WHAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO IS
CREATE A CERTIFICATE?
OF PROFICIENCY.
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO ADVANCE
THE NEEDS OF THE SPECIAL NEEDS
POPULATION.
THE PROVIDERS ARE AN ESSENTIAL
SERVICE WHEN YOU TALK TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS OR FAMILIES WHO
HAVE A LOVED ONE WHO IS SPECIAL
NEEDS.
ARE THEY GETTING THE APPROPRIATE
SERVICES [inaudible]
PROBABLY NOT.
BUT THE ONES THAT ARE THANK GOD
THAT THEY ARE.
SO FOR EVERY BAD THING THAT YOU
HEAR THERE'S A GOOD.
THERE ARE GOOD THINGS ARE
HAPPENING FOR THE POPULATION
ALSO.
BUT WE NEED TO WORK FROM THE AND
START PLANNING BACKWARDS FROM
THE PROVIDERS FROM THE WORK
FORCE WE NEED TO BUILD THAT.
THEN WE CAN ASSURE HOW MUCH
MONEY WE NEED. TO GO FORWARD WE
NEED TO BUILD THE BUSINESS PLAN
FOR THIS POPULATION AND SHOW
THEM THAT THEY MATTER TO US.
I STRONGLY URGE.
YOUR AYE VOTE.
BUT I ALSO URGE.
THANK YOU CARE AND YOU WORK
TOWARDS THIS WEEK FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THE THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE DESPERATELY NEED YOUR HELP.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE ITEM [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF WE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
ASSES IN WITHOUT OBJECTION
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL. TO THE
SENATE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE CURRENT FILE.
AND TAKE UP THE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY NINE AB [inaudible]
EIGHT NINETY ONE CORRECT.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY ONE BY
FAMILY MEMBER BURKE AND OTHERS
AND EXPLAIN TO TAXATION MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO CLIMB
THE URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MS BERKLEY AVAILABLE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB NINETY ONE
THE LOOPHOLE CLOSERS SMALL
BUSINESS AND WORKING FAMILIES
TAX RELIEF ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE SPEAKER IN ALL OF
THE MEMBERS FOR THEIR HARD WORK
AND BRING.
THIS BILL TO THE FLOOR AS WELL
AS THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS BOLD
INITIATIVE.
AB NINETY ONE MAKE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES IN PROVIDERS TANGIBLE
BENEFITS IN THE FOLLOWING WAYS.
IT PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY MILLION IN RELIEF BY
SIMPLIFYING ACCOUNTING RULES FOR
SMALL BUSINESS WITH UP TO TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IN GROSS RECEIPTS
BY ALLOWING THEM TO LIKE CASH
RATHER THAN A MORE COMPLICATED
ACCRUAL METHOD.
OF ACCOUNTING.
STUDENT LOANS OR DISCHARGE DUE
TO DEATH OR DISABILITY WILL NO
LONGER BE INCLUDED IN GROSS
INCOME THIS BILL WILL ALSO HELP
THE NEEDIEST IN OUR SOCIETY BY
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO ROLL
OVER FUNDS FROM THE FIVE TWENTY
NINE EDUCATION ACCOUNT. TO AN
ABLE ACCOUNT WITHOUT PENALTY AND
INCREASING THE AMOUNT THAT A
BENEFIT FOR YOU CAN CONTRIBUTE
TO THEIR OWN ABLE ACCOUNT.
IT IMPROVES THE STATE'S LONG
TERM FINANCIAL STABILITY BY
CLOSING A SERIES OF LOOPHOLES
THAT PROVIDE UNJUSTIFIED TAX
BREAKS A BIT SPECIFICALLY IT
WOULD CLOSE THE EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION LOOPHOLE.
LIMIT THE LOSSES ON NON
CORPORATE TAXPAYERS THAT CAN BE
TAKEN IN ANY GIVEN YEAR.
ELIMINATE AND NO WELL KERRY BACK
SO THE NEXT TIME WE ENTER INTO
RECESSION WE WON'T HAVE TO CUT
HEALTH CARE SCHOOLS OR OTHER
VITAL SOCIAL AND PUBLIC SAFETY
SERVICES.
REPEAL THE TECHNICAL TERMINATION
OF PARTNERSHIPS.
AND AND THE TECHNICAL.
TERMINATION OF PARTNERSHIPS.
AS CHAIR OF THE REVENUE AND TAX
COMMITTEE I AM ACUTELY AWARE.
OF THE DIRECT IMPACT TAX POLICY
ON THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS.
NOWHERE IS THIS IMPACT CLEARER
THAN IN THE CASE OF THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT.
AND ALL THE CO THOUGH THE CREDIT
HAS BEEN A VITAL PART OF LIFTING
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
THIS BILL WILL EXTEND THE CREDIT
TO INDIVIDUALS MAKING UP TO
THIRTY THOUSAND A YEAR.
INCREASE THE CREDIT PROGRAM BY
AN ADDITIONAL SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
PROVIDES A NEW YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT OF ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN UNDER.
SIX CALIFORNIA IS THE RICHEST
STATE IN THE COUNTRY AND YET WE
HAVE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN LIVING IN DEEP POVERTY.
THESE ARE FAMILIES OF FOUR THAT
ARE LIVING ON UNDER THIRTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
THEY HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
KEEPING THE LIGHTS ON AND
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE.
THEY LIE AWAKE AT NIGHT WORRIED
ABOUT PAYING THE RENT.
THEY ARE THE WORKING POOR AND
THEY ARE STRUGGLING.
THEY NEED THIS HELP AND THEY
WORK EVERY DAY TO EARN IT.
IT IS ON THEIR BEHALF.
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE BILL.
THANK YOU MS BURKE MISS ROBIN
ONLY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
NINETY ONE THIS BILL AN AXE
SELECTIVE CONFORMITY WITH
FEDERAL TAX LAW AND USES SOME OF
THE SAVINGS FROM THAT CONFORMITY
TO FUND AN INCREASE IN THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT.
HOWEVER THE ITEMS THAT THIS BILL
SELECTS TO CONFORM WITH SALIM
VERY SELECTIVELY CHOSEN. TO
MAXIMIZE STATE REVENUE RATHER
THAN AN HONEST.
EFFORT TO CONFORM TO FEDERAL TAX
LAW AND LET ME GIVE YOU JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF THAT WHICH THE
TREATMENT OF LIKE A KIND
EXCHANGES.
THE FEDERAL TAX CUT AND JOB ACTS
OF LAST YEAR.
ELIMINATED LIKE KIND EXCHANGES
FOR MANY TYPES OF PROPERTY BUT
AT THE SAME TIME ENACTED CHANGES
TO THE STATE'S DEPRECIATION
RULES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
APPRECIATION RULES.
THAT MADE IT SO THE MOST
TAXPAYERS WERE NOT HARMED BY
THIS ACTION HOWEVER THIS BILL
ELIMINATES LIKE KIND OF CHANGES
WITHOUT CONFORMING TO TAX CODE
ON FIRST YEAR EXPENSING.
AND I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A
CONCRETE EXAMPLE OF WHAT THAT
MEANS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S VERY
LITTLE UNDERSTOOD LET'S SAY THAT
YOU OWN A SMALL BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT YOU INVEST A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN A NEW
COMPUTER SYSTEM FOR YOUR
BUSINESS AND LET'S SAY A FEW
YEARS LATER THAT YOUR BUSINESS
HAS GROWN AND YOU NEED A NEW
COMPUTER SYSTEM.
AND THAT YOU CAN SYSTEM WILL
COST YOU TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS YOU BY THE NEW SYSTEM.
AND YOU SELL YOUR OLD SYSTEM FOR
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WELL
UNDER CURRENT STATE LAW YOU
DECLARE A LIKE KIND EXCHANGE SO
THE FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT
YOU GOT FOR YOUR OLD SYSTEM.
IS CREDITED AGAINST THE NEW
SYSTEM AND YOU DEPRECIATE THE
NEW SYSTEM AT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND IF YOU PASS THIS
BILL TODAY.
YOU WILL REQUIRE BUSINESS OWNERS
TO PAY INCOME TAX ON THE FIFTY
THOUSAND THEY GOT FOR THEIR OLD
SYSTEM EVEN THOUGH THE FACT THEY
NEVER EVEN GOT THAT MONEY.
THEY WENT ALL INTO AN INVESTMENT
IN THE NEW SYSTEM THAT IS NOT
CLOSING A LOOP HOLE THAT IS NOT
FAIR AND THAT IS NOT CONFORMITY.
YESTERDAY IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WE HEARD TESTIMONY
FROM SEVERAL AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS WHO TESTIFIED THAT
THIS WILL CREATE IT
SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER LEASE RATES
FOR ANY AUTOMOBILE LEAST IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE LEASING
COMPANIES TO PAY INCOME TAX ON
THE VALUE.
OF THE VEHICLES AT THAT I'LL
TRADE BACK IN ON NEW VEHICLES.
DO YOU EVERYONE IN THIS CHAMBER
SHOULD CARE ABOUT THAT
PARTICULARLY IF YOU CARE ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
BECAUSE WE ALL WANT INCENTIVIZE
NEW ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN
CALIFORNIA WILL GUESS WHAT --
OVER 90% OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES
ARE LEAST THEY'RE NOT PURCHASED
AND OF THOSE ARE MORE EXPENSIVE
FEWER PEOPLE WILL BUY THEM.
SO THIS BILL DEFINITELY NEEDS
SOME -- SOME MORE BAKING OTHER
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL THAT ARE
SUPPORTABLE BUT THE THE
PROVISIONS ON TAX CONFORMITY
REALLY NEED TO BE RETHOUGHT I
URGE A NO VOTE.
MS RACE YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ALTHOUGH I AM GLAD TO
SEE SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION TO THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT OR EITC.
IN THIS BILL I AM STILL
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE CREDIT
CONTINUES TO EXCLUDE PEOPLE FILE
WITH AN INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER OR
NINETEEN AND EXPANSION OF THE
AYE TO SEEK TO INDIVIDUALS WITH
ITUNES WAS PRESENT.
IN BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
VERSIONS OF THE BUDGET WHAT HAS
BEEN REMOVED AS A PART OF THE
LARGER NEGOTIATION AROUND TAX
STRUCTURE.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
I TUNES ARE TAXPAYERS.
AND THE PLAY A SIGNIFICANT ROLE
IN THEIR LOCAL ECONOMIES YET
THEY DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
CRITICAL SERVICES MEANT TO
SUPPORT LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
THIS ACT TO TRULY BE A WORKING
FAMILIES TAX RELIEF IT SHOULD
SUPPORT ALL FAMILIES AND NOT
SURE CHANGE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
OR EVEN ONE PERSON IN THE
HOUSEHOLD FILES AND I WITH AN
AYE TEN THE ENTIRE FAMILY IS
DENIED THE CREDIT.
I AM COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND HOPE THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE.
WILL FOLLOW THROUGH FOR LOW
INCOME IMMIGRANTS.
AND LOW INCOME IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE THANK
YOU.
THERE WAS RESIDENTS KILEY YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES -- I THINK THERE'S A
REAL MISSED OPPORTUNITY IN THIS
BILL AND THAT THERE'S NO
CONFORMITY WITH FEDERAL
OPPORTUNITIES OWN TAX BENEFITS.
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS ARE A NEW
BIPARTISAN TOOL FOR COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DESIGN TO PROVIDE
TAX INCENTIVES DELP UNLOCK
CAPITAL TO INVEST IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
UNDER FEDERAL LAW INVESTORS CAN
NOW TO FOR PAYING TAX ON CAPITAL
GAINS IF THOSE GAINS ARE
INVESTED IN QUALIFIED
OPPORTUNITY FUNDS THAT IN TURN
INVEST IN ECONOMICALLY
DISTRESSED COMMUNITIES.
IN ADDITION TO THE DEFERRAL OF
GAME LONG TERM INVESTMENT IS
INCENTIVIZE BY ALLOWING FOR A
MODEST STEP UP IN BASIS FOR
INVESTMENTS.
AS AN ADDITIONAL INCENTIVE TO
MAKE A LONG TERM PATIENT CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS TAXPAYERS HOLDING
OPPORTUNITY FUND INVESTMENTS FOR
A PERIOD OF AT LEAST TEN YEARS.
ARE EXEMPT FROM ANY ADDITIONAL
GAINES BEYOND THAT WHICH WAS
PREVIOUSLY INVESTED.
FOLLOWING ADD THESE CHANGES THE
FEDERAL TAX LAW MOST STATES HAVE
FOLLOWED SUIT.
AT LEAST FORTY STATES EITHER
DON'T HAVE TAX CAPITAL GAINS OR
HAVE FULL OR PARTIAL CONFORMITY
WITH THE NEW FEDERAL OPPORTUNITY
TAX ON BENEFITS BUT CALIFORNIA
STILL ISN'T ONE OF THEM.
AT A CRITICAL TIME WHEN
INVESTORS WILL BE MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE TO INVEST
THIS PUTS US AT A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE AS FAR AS
ATTRACTING CAPITAL FOR HOUSING
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT
MOST SO I HOPE WE CAN CONNECT
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
CONFORMITY WITH FEDERAL
OPPORTUNITIES OWN TAX BENEFITS
AND TAKE PROPER ACTION SO THE
CALIFORNIA CAN REAP THE FULL
BENEFITS OF OPPORTUNITIES OUT
ITS THANK YOU.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL THE DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
MS BURKE YOU MAY CLOSE.
I LIKE TO THINK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THEIR COMMENTS AND I WOULD
LIKE TO STATE THAT I SHARE THE
SAME CONCERN ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT COVER.
I TENS UM I AM COMMITTED IN MY
FUTURE WORK TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON ON THAT ISSUE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ME MY COLLEAGUES HAVE EXPRESS
IT IT'S IMPORTANT TO THEM.
AND I DO BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THING IS WORKING WITH THAT THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
NINE KNOWS TWO ONE THE URGENCY.
EYES FIFTY NINE KNOWS TO ON THE
MEASURE SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRED IN
--
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS THIRTIES
THIRTY EIGHT AND THIRTY NINE ARE
TO BE CONTINUED.
MEMBERS.
WE WILL MOVE TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THIS IS THE SECOND A CONSENT
THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR.
BEFORE WE VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WILL FIRST TAKE UP
RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE ON CONSENT
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ADDING CO
AUTHORS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE ONE ROLL CALL VOTE AND
ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A
CO AUTHOR. TO THE RESOLUTIONS
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT LUCIEN
EIGHTY NINE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
COOLEY RELATIVE TO SPECIAL
DISTRICT WEEK AS A MAKING HER
RESOLUTION NINETY FOUR BY
SOMETHING MEMBER RAY IS RELATIVE
TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY THREE BY
SOME REMEMBER MCCARTY BELTED A
WORLD REFUGEE DAY.
THE CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE
TO ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO ADD ON AS
A CO AUTHOR TO THE RESOLUTIONS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTIONS [inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
NINE CO AUTHORS ADDED.
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO A VOTE
ON THE CONSENT.
CALENDAR MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE SB THIRTY SIX HERTZBERG
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT CONSENT.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
A SOMETHING CURRENT VERSION
EIGHTY NINE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
COOLEY RELATIVE TO SPECIAL
DISTRICTS WEEK.
AND THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VETERANS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
MARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE IN TELEVOTE EYES
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON CONSENT.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY FOUR EYES SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY
THREE I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY FIVE I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO AND SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY THREE HIGHS
SEVENTY FIVE KNOWS.
ZERO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS THERE
WILL BE A HEALTH COMMITTEE
HEARING IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO
UPON A GERMAN OF SESSION.
THAT'S HEALTH COMMITTEE IN ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH TWO UPON A GERMAN.
OF SESSION THE SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY JUNE TWENTY
FIRST NO FLOOR SESSION NO CHECK
IN SESSION.
MONDAY JUNE TWENTY FOURTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION.
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THE GERMANS
IN MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE GREEN CARPET
.
THE REMAINING MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR
.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR.
PLEASE GIVE A RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES.
WHO WILL BE A TURNING IN THE
MEMORY
?
MR LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN A MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
TODAY I ASKED WE JOURNEY IN
MEMORY A LONG TIME MENTAL VALLEY
RESIDENT LEROY ALLEY.
HE PASSED AWAY JUNE ELEVENTH
WITH HIS CHILDREN AT THE SIDE OF
HIS BIBLE IN HIS HANDS.
LEROY WAS BORN.
ON HIS GRANDPARENTS FARM NEAR LA
VERNIA TEXAS IN.
NINETEEN FORTY TWO HE SPENT HIS
EARLY YEARS LIVING ON THE FARM
WHERE HE LEARNED TO DRIVE A
TRACTOR AT AGE.
FIVE AND HELP THIS FAMILY
HARVEST CORN PEANUTS AND HEY.
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL LEROY SERVED
IN THE NATIONAL GUARD WHICH
INCLUDED FIVE AND A HALF MONTHS
OF ACTIVE DUTY.
AS A COMBAT MEDIC.
LEROY LATER BECAME ACQUAINTED
WITH THE FUNERAL BUSINESS WHEN
HE WOULD SPEND TIME WITH HIS
FATHER WHO WORKED IN THE
MORTUARY.
AFTER STUDYING PRE MED FREE
YEARLY RIGHT DECIDED TO ATTEND
MORTUARY SCHOOL NETWORK FOR
VARIOUS MORTUARIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
HE LATER MOVED TO THE OTTAWA
VALLEY WORRY OPERATED.
WHAT WOULD BECOME THE HALLE
OLSON MURPHY MORTUARY?
DURING HIS FIFTY THREE YEARS IN
THE OTTAWA VALLEY RIGHT BECAME
INVOLVED IN THE COMMUNITY WHERE
HE WAS A BOARD MEMBER.
OF THE ALABAMA A FAIR
ASSOCIATION WAS LATER APPOINTED
BY THE GOVERNOR TO THE FIFTIETH.
DISTRICT AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATION BOARD.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS THREE
CHILDREN BRIAN CLINTON INDIANA.
AS WELL AS NINE GRANDCHILDREN
ONE GREAT GRANDCHILD.
I ASK YOU THAT YOU JOIN ME IN A
JOINING IN HIS MEMORY AND THE WE
REMEMBER VETERANS FOR THEIR
EVERY DAY COUNTLESS SACRIFICES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY
[inaudible]
MS IRWIN.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ASK
YOU TO JOIN ME IN A CHURNING IN
THE MEMORY OF BRENDAN JEWEL HERE
ALL.
GET ANOTHER CHILD OF INTER
COUNTY LOST MUCH TOO EARLY.
BORN AUGUST TWENTIETH NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE RENDON WAS JUST
CONQUERING THE ROLE OF BECOMING
AN ADULT.
TIME WITH HIS FAMILY WAS HIS
GREATEST JOY.
AND HE TREASURED HIS SPECIAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS SISTER
MEGAN.
AFTER COMPLETING HIS STUDIES AT
CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO IN
AGRICULTURAL BUSINESS BRENNAN
BEGAN HIS CAREER WITH TALLY
FARMS.
FEEDING THE WORLD WITH
NUTRITIOUS FOOD GROWN WITH
EXCELLENCE HE LATER JOINED THE
FAMILY BUSINESS DISTRIBUTING A
BOUNTY OF HEALTHY FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY
COUNTRY.
HEALTHY LIVING WAS A GUIDING
FORCE FOR BRANDON AS A SECOND
FAMILY WAS IS CROSSFIT COMMUNITY
WHO ENCOURAGED ALL TO BE THEIR
BEST SELVES.
HE WAS AN EXCELLENT ATHLETE WHO
ENJOY THE GREAT OUTDOORS.
OVER FORTY FRIENDS AND LOVED
ONES JOINT LOVED ONES JOIN TO
PADDLE OUT TO REMEMBER BROWN AND
AN AVID SURFER.
WHOSE LOVE OF THE OCEAN AND
SUSTAINING ITS HEALTH AND BEAUTY
WAS A LIFELONG GOAL.
BRANDON WAS THE ULTIMATE FRIEND
CONSTANTLY CHECKING IN ON
FRIENDS AND COMPANIONS.
HE WAS THOUGHTFUL AND CARING TO
ALL THOSE WHO CROSSED HIS PATH
HE WILL BE MISSED BUT IN THE
SHORT TIME HE WAS WITH US.
HE MADE A LIVE DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES OF ALL WHO KNEW HIM.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST WHICH YOUR
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OF THE ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN A MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER GALLAGHER MOVES AND
MISTER COOPER SECONDS AT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY JUNE TWENTY FOURTH.
AT ONE PM.
WE ARE ADJOURNED